hey what's up guys my name is a
Chenoweth the episode 74 of game
programming so last time which was a
while ago we took a look at projectile
fire right well we just talked about how
to make the player fire projectiles
slower now today we're going to cover
collision detection for project Al's and
I'll talk about what that is a minute
but um yeah I'm sorry about the long
length between episodes I have finished
my maths exam which went pretty well
and yesterday I handed it my 230 page
programming folio so that's all done I'm
actually finished first semester of uni
which is awesome
anyway uni is University for those
people who inevitably don't know anyway
so collision detection for projectiles
you can see here that if we walk we
can't actually cross this wall over here
because while we're colliding with it
now similar thing should probably happen
with these projectiles you can say that
they just fly over this this little
thing here we don't want them to do that
right or maybe you do but I'm just gonna
say that we don't for now yeah and the
thing with this is that we have to think
of a way to basically destroy them upon
collision so let's um let's talk about
that and that that I can actually be
very interesting because um the reason
why is projectiles are pretty fast
especially um stuff like if if we do
make a sniper sort of thing that
traveled like it's like a bullet it
travels ridiculously fast my trap it
might travel like I don't know SP
realistic here maybe like 10 tiles per
second like honestly that's actually
pretty slow isn't it 10 tiles for per
frame is what I meant to say but that's
um that would be 10 times 60 which is
600 so 600 tiles per second and the
problem with that is it will simply skip
over this wall right especially these
one tile walls these projectiles will
simply get you know to the wall because
as you can see they're animated in steps
and it will plus equals the vector to
give their new position in the world and
their new position might be over here
and it's already past the wall so
there's no collision being it did
because well we made it past the wall so
we need to talk about that as well but
first let's make some basically a
collision detection so that went on when
these projectiles actually hit a wall or
any solid object they disappear okay so
let's talk about how would you do that
so how do we shoot let's go back and
figure that out because I've kind of a
dozen up there shooting okay so okay so
there's a um aha I say let's go to with
the projectile so this is how we move
and what we should do here is really
detect collision between these two
entities so let's talk about how it you
knew that because there are multiple
ways of doing that you can see that
we've already got the code in our mob
class yeah
sorry over here collision what I might
actually do is I'm just thinking I might
make a universal version of this method
so that instead of having to copy and
paste this code basically we could just
say yeah let's just make it I don't
really want to do that for here though
just because we've actually set these
values to be perfect but what I will do
so I'll leave this here but I will copy
it so I'm not gonna cut it I'm gonna
copy it and I want to put it into our
level class and I've decided that now
level class
that's where well that's where we will
do the collision between and between
entities so first thing we should do is
it was a projectile and make sure that
level is actually here somehow and I
think it is because projectile extends
entity annex and empty gives us a level
which is brilliant actually so let's go
back to here try this over here I think
we use a level donut anyway I know I
don't
that's annoying no sir over here in
level I'm just gonna paste that that
math that function whatever you want to
call it get rid of this and what we'll
have to do is give an x and a y and this
will be a collision between this will be
like a tile collision and Calum is gonna
call it as helpful in x and y will be
the what i call it x and y will be the
position sorry i'm kind of half tired i
know x and y will be the position of our
entity that is going to possibly collide
with the tile and x and y i will be the
look at the basically the direction
which is heading now one thing that's
important here to notice the size
because this is essentially be size
I'm gonna get rid of this and what I'm
actually gonna do here is I'm gonna say
we know how big tiles ask that's not
really a problem but over here I'm going
to put in the size and this will be the
size of our object so like our player
might be 64 I think it is 64 actually uh
nothing I play is 32 and something like
a little projectile might be like what
is it like eight or something I don't
know really small it's probably more
like four or five but yeah this would be
our size and I'm just gonna look through
this this should work pretty well okay
private
we definitely need to make this public
and let's check out how this can work
so in Wizard projectile what we need to
do is only move if we detect collisions
so if there is no collision
so if level dot what I call it tile
Persian yep
or rather we move if we do not detect
collision so if the path is clear so x
and y will be the x and y position or
location of our projectile x and y will
be where they move so we can actually
put an accent and y here now that's
gonna make kind of a problem that you'll
see but that's alright we can fix that
later and the reason is NX and wine
actually X&Y that
they're not integers but we'll talk
about that in a minute and sighs I'm
probably gonna put about 64 for now I
know that it's not actually 64 but you
know whatever
and then we can move in those directions
if that's my question we don't need to
worry about sliding so there's really no
no reason to split so okay so over here
I'll change these faster doubles and
I'll actually calculate the collision
pretty much to a double except for here
it'll be the cost up to that but um I
will try and calculate it to a double as
best as I can in fact it's probably why
that it costs X and these guys to
actually I'm not sure where this will
actually result in let's just check out
so XT plus yeah okay there we go
I forgot the white whoops okay
so that'll print out what we actually
get cuz I'm not sure so I only move it
there's no collision so let's check out
how that works I'm not even sure if yeah
okay we crashed because level is not
okay that's because we don't actually
formally add
projectile that's the one on the floor
that we probably need to fix right now
and that is um the reason that it's
throwing us a nullpointerexception is
because when we shoot level that a
projectile oh and we do at it but the
thing that we are into is probably
initialize it this is in level right so
we should just probably do something
like this why is invisible how do we
always initialize it that's how we do it
okay that's fine I can do that we've got
to make sure that we actually set level
to the current levels that's cool we
should probably work yep okay so you can
see how that kind of works or almost
works okay so it seems that it thinks
that is the bottom there is some
offsetting here and that's cool
I believe yeah okay so that works okay I
know it doesn't huh what's happening
here I think it's because of all right
wow this is really varied isn't it okay
so we need to tweak this obviously
that's to be expected we need it we need
to tweak this to UM get it to be correct
this is I think this is relatively good
though let's try and go back to level
and where is our little tile collision
method here it is instead of maybe doing
this let's cast these individual things
to integers and leave this as an integer
and I'll cost this that might give us
pretty different effects
okay 28:59 okay you can say the what do
you call it the the rounding is probably
more accurate now that looks pretty good
okay great so we've got some problems
and they seem to be with this side and
that's just probably because of our um
well what happened there so low okay
that's probably because of our arm out
size and how we didn't sort of do things
correctly so let's I think if we divide
size by maybe about a tall sword I'll
see what we get then okay huh actually
moves live I don't know do that why did
you do that
that's really weird oh because I keep on
flying yeah my bad so this is getting a
bit more accurate as you can see I think
if we just add about that's really cool
actually how they'll update live how
does on is very fun they won't go back
what's that obviously there isn't they
update live by the way if you guys don't
get it is because um hang on let me fix
this quickly the reason that they'll
actually update live is because I don't
actually I don't think thing we don't
need to do that anyway let me focus on
what I'm trying to say
that's pretty good that's pretty good as
well okay the reason that they update
live is because they keep on flying
after we because we basically since they
all still exist mail they are all still
checking for collision and they're all
trying to move but they can't move
because they're colliding because that's
still going on when we change the
collision it checks again to see if you
can move in a can
so it advances forward until it can't
anymore so that's good let's just
restart this thing so we get rid of
those entities and I can see clearly
alright that's looking pretty good you
can see obviously they varied us
depending on how many steps they take
per frame probably need to play around
with Y a bit so let's maybe probably do
the same thing for y I think part of the
reason that this is happening as well as
because we've really um their size is
really you know like not true basically
for your batter was a potato size is
definitely not 64 so let's make it if
that's easy Falls massive let's make it
um that's actually you know I offered a
better idea why don't we stop guessing
why don't we actually open up our card
and turn it out it's a very casual upset
is not a lot of you guys like the cattle
one so oh my god not gonna try to make
this professional okay um
where are we here we go so it's cool
with it
- hey alrighty here we go
sorry let's measure how big this is this
is centered which is good
sent it as good if it wasn't the top
left without problems okay so this is
frickin will you tell me what the error
is that I've selected please okay yeah
okay seven by seven that is that's
pretty good so input seven here let's
close this and reopen
okay wise got problem X is actually
pretty accurate surprise line let's go
back to tile collision okay um let's get
rid of that and let's probably play
around with this bit more and I think it
might be I should walk faster for me
yeah I can't brilliant so I think if we
just subtract like or add it's probably
too much maybe like six I guess I'm not
pretty good
now you know on the X front that's
perfect I think that's decent if we
subtract like or okay that's perfect
I got I think we've gotten X done pretty
well
yeah okay X is perfect right now pretty
much let's just get rid of this divided
thing I don't really need that do we
yeah we did
okay and all we need to do is oh my this
is a very um what do you call it not
only time consuming it's just like a
tweaking thing and I you guys like to
say the entire process of making this
game obviously so I am giving you the
entire process of making this game and
that is just tweaking in so we left
it'll be hop this list I'm just so that
we get on we can hop this now we can get
a much more precise head yeah that's
okay I'm gonna leave X like that for now
so it's divided by two which I can just
change to this minus five yeah okay I'm
not gonna use that because I could but
the reason is that for some reason
bitwise I've already same to occur you
know like I think on the same level
priority as addition and subtraction so
the problem with that obviously is that
you need for us everywhere because it
wants to multiply sorry yeah it wants to
multiply it before it does the bitwise
operation so that's the issue of why
that isn't working I should be able to
do roughly the same thing for y here
let's check out how this is looking
okay I'm gonna leave it like that for
now okay so they're both divided by four
minus five and divided by 2 plus 5
there's the values that I used as you
can see and that seems to work pretty
well you can see that they stick you so
now everything works perfectly except
that we obviously don't want to stick
here we want them to just disappear yeah
so we can do that in a really simple way
because we can just say we don't even
need to do a move like this we can
actually take that out and what we can
say is if they do indeed collide let's
actually move this to the update method
moving if they do actually collide here
then let's just remove them and we can
remove them by calling remove I believe
how we do it that way I think that's
yeah yeah sure what okay so I just
forgot the names okay I didn't why let's
go back to our thingy and the reason
that didn't work is because we get it
did not so if there is a collision
detection if if collision is detected in
a roof yeah self-explanatory I don't do
paralyzed and there we go so they're
disappear which is nice you might want
to put this a bit more you can say that
they are kind of going past here if that
my recommendation probably be just to
make it so they disappear like earlier
so maybe if you make this idiom
oops I think if we make this like this
then yeah something like that where they
actually disappeared before they hit the
wall rather than at the wall it'll just
look better so that's some my time to
multiply this out to make to make that
effect yeah okay that's pretty good
where we go where did we go here we go
okay
and I'll probably do the same for all
right up with plus I got that didn't
exactly walk
I think I need to make this map a bit
more turbo friendly don't I
cuz right now it's just a bit um okay
that's pretty good yeah okay I'm gonna
leave it like that for now okay
the other thing that we could create and
we might talk about this next episode
actually is um particles so I when it
when a thing does collide we might just
release a bunch of like smoke particles
or something like that just to show that
there is some kind of collision going on
and just to make it just to make the
game look better graphically so yeah
anyway guys I hope you enjoyed this
pretty boring episode of game
programming but it needed to be done and
it wasn't actually that boring was kind
of fun probably be more fun twerking it
yourself obviously but um I'll just get
rid of this system dot out dot print
line and yeah you can see now that we've
got what I get rid of oh my bad
yeah you can see now that we've got
collision for projectile yeah anyway I
hope you enjoyed this episode of game
programming if you did please hit the
like button I've got a pretty big
announcement to make as well which you
guys will see maybe a few hours after
this video but um until then let guys
you